seth macfarlane said in the audition for
uh
family guy you were off the rails he
says
when you know when you go in for an
audition sometimes 99 of the time you
think
this is what it reads as this is what it
is this is uh i'm the
whatever the the stone guy or the surfer
kid or whatever it is
and i'm gonna read it like oh they want
to surf first so i'll be like oh hey man
what's going on brah
oh they want a stoner guy it's like hey
man are they and so you go in
what was it like going in for family guy
what was going through your mind
um i had been digging around
with charlie corso for over a week
doing an impersonation of ted levine
from
uh silence of the lambs right right
right charlie came into town
to do the press junket for can't hardly
wait
and we spent the week um they sent us
all of the clippings right like they're
like hey here's all the press points you
got and it was at the time
for a copied pronounce with
all of our reviews i don't know if you
know this the reviews of that movie were
not kind
and they singled out each of the actors
individually
and in more than 10
just attacked our physical aesthetic oh
so charlie and i were like all right we
had just done
not a mean-spirited press junket but you
know a lot of people are like why did
you make this
and so you you i got to the point where
we weren't even defensive we were just
like let's just have fun with this
we were highlighting every um
category of insult and then just sort of
walking each other through the
ptsd oh my god and um he stayed with me
and i don't even know how we got off on
the topic but we just started talking
about the character from silence in the
lambs
getting odd jobs and
doing everything from being a roller
rink dj
which i love to trying to order
something at jack in the box
because that his character is so
specific and he
does this really dark kind of thing
oh wait a minute
[Laughter]
is she a great big fat person
i've been doing that impression for
years too i just i'm enamored by that
guy
and i finally worked with him and i'm
like hey dude's like oh good how are you
i'm like holy [ __ ] you talk like that
he's a brilliant actor oh yeah
performance is incredible but that
character was so indelible that we just
joked around putting like mimicking the
whole thing and so
i read that script for family guy and i
loved it i wanted it you know what i
mean it was so
funny i was like ah this will never last
on tv but let me be a part of it
and so i i came in and i did the like
what's up dodge
fight the machine and did the whole
surfer thing and i was like can i this
may be stupid but can i try
something you know what i mean and it's
always that it's always the risk that
you take
it's always the i got i got a lot of
jobs that didn't
read um from a stage uh stage direction
standpoint
as me right i'm 5'4 i'm redheaded i'm
very pale
and i'm not what you call conventionally
attractive but i
have a lot of personality right and
that's always that's always kept me
going
so i like to try [ __ ] you know most
casting people
it's like they want something specific
but what they really
notice is somebody that churns
and you never shine doing it the way oh
it
it organically reads this way right you
gotta
add something the actors that we both
love
they're just they're in it